هناك 16 دولة
تعاني من الصراعات وهي في
أعلى مرتبة من الضعف المناخي، لذا فإن
السودان وجنوب السودان المتأثرين بالصراعات هما
اليمن وأفغانستان، فأنت تعرف
القصص التي قمت بتغطيتها هناك
وفي هذه الأماكن ما تراه
هو ذلك  الصراع يؤدي إلى تفاقم
الفقر، ومن ثم تؤدي أزمة المناخ إلى تفاقم
الفقر أيضًا وأنا أستخدم
كلمة أزمة المناخ وليس
تغير المناخ لأنه في البلدان التي
نعمل فيها إنها أزمة، تذكروا
هذا أيضًا في
تلك البلدان الستة عشر، ما مقدار
الانبعاثات العالمية التي تنتجها؟  المسؤول عن
الإجابة
2% ما هي النسبة المئوية للكوارث المناخية التي
يعانون منها 40% ما
هي نسبة الاحتياجات الإنسانية في تلك البلدان الـ 16 فقط
60% حتى تتمكن من رؤية أن
أزمة المناخ والصراع
المحلي والحروب الأهلية
تتفاقم أحيانًا  من قبل لاعبين خارجيين يجعلون الحياة
بؤسًا مطلقًا للأشخاص الذين يعيشون على
حافة الهاوية، حيث أن 10% فقط من سكان العالم يعيشون
في تلك البلدان، لكنهم يمثلون 50
% و60% من الاحتياجات الإنسانية، وهم يعتمدون على
منظمات مثل منظمتنا، إذا كانت هذه هي
رسالتك هنا وبحق
إذًا ما هو الحل، فالرسالة
هنا هي أن العديد من مؤتمرات رجال الشرطة
للأحزاب كانت تدور حول كلمات، وهذا يحتاج
إلى أن يكون شرطيًا حول العمل، العمل،
العمل، حتى يتمكن الناس من
رؤية التغيير الحقيقي للأشخاص الذين
نتحدث عنهم  تقوم هذه البلدان الستة عشر
برسم خريطة للمخاطر بشكل صحيح حتى
تعرف أين
تأتي الفيضانات عندما يأتي الجفاف، يمكننا
توقع ذلك ثانيًا: الابتكار
نحتاج إلى تعزيز البذور من النوع الذي
نقوم به في شمال شرق سوريا وفي
باكستان، نحتاج إلى مساعدة
المجتمعات المحلية  سواء كانوا ريفيين أو حضريين يتكيفون
حتى يتمكنوا من عزل أنفسهم
عن بعض أسوأ آثار
تغير المناخ ثالثًا، دعونا نتوقف عن
الخوف من المجتمع المدني
كشريك في توصيل بنوك التنمية المتعددة الأطراف
في الوقت الحالي الذي نتعامل فيه على أننا
استثنائيون عندما تكون تلك المؤسسات المتعددة الأطراف
العمل معنا، لا، يجب أن
نكون في مركز الصدارة، ثم أخيرًا
كم مرة سمعت NOS تقول إننا
بحاجة إلى المزيد من التمويل الإنساني أو تقول إننا
بحاجة إلى المزيد من التمويل المناخي